so our first lecture
um our first talk actually it's life
death and chopping
so every minute
300 million cells die in the human body
and this is what we're going to talk
about today yes right here sorry to
interrupt your uh screen share looks
super small okay please share your
screen
sure yeah
um
let me rearrange it sorry
oops sorry
is it better much better thank you okay
great
okay
um
so every minute three million cells die
in the human body and this is what we're
going to talk about today and we're
going to talk about death failure or
success depending on your point of view
what do we predict death engine failure
churn or purchase a prediction
the basic concept is the same as we are
predicting events over timeline
usually survival analysis models predict
time until a time until event the
duration of a cycle and team until the
occurrence of an event and what I'm
going to offer in this talk is a
different perspective in which we take
all the past history of a device or user
and use that history in order to predict
the future
and this is exactly what I did in my
last position I'm a data scientist
um in my current position I'm building
acoustic modeling models
um my thesis topic is classifying online
persuasion and last uh in my last
position and I am I what I did was
purchase a prediction
so this is Alex and Bob very nice to
meet him
uh those are actually two years users in
a retail platform their activities
contains a different web pages over time
such as category and search
um and detailed pages of different kind
of of items
and what we want to predict using a we
want to predict whether or not Alice and
Bob will actually purchase in the near
future
so what we want to do is aggregate all
their past events in order to predict
whether or not they will purchase
something in the near future
we can use the two weeks before in order
to predict what that what will happen in
the third week and use the data uh from
week two and three in order to predict
the fourth week and so on
what we want to do is use moving Windows
um of the data
so if something happened in in all kind
of different dates uh for Alice and
Volvo and we want to
um get those that those data points
points according to a specific date in
which we will run some kind of a machine
learning model
so we have all kind of different
modeling run dates and we want to see
um what is the relevance Day from a
specific event to that modeling date
in order to do that
um
we we take the first week and the second
week to predict the third week the
second and the third week to predict the
first week and so on
and we will try to avoid dates and user
uh from overlapping when we're dealing
with the evaluation of our models
so when we are creating those data
points we're creating it over time with
some kind of a date list
and then we cast it to our data frame
and after we we create that feature in
our
in the in our
um in our data frame we calculate the
relevance date to that day and the
relevance date the distance from that
relevant day of the model
um
and then we filter out all kind of data
points that are Irrelevant for our data
collection
for example maybe something that
happened three weeks ago or three months
ago isn't relevant to what we want to
predict because it's too far away and
it's just a noise in our model in our
data modeling
so we actually offend it's it's key it's
kind of
um
um creates all kind of
um duplicates our data frame according
to each and every model around it and we
create we aggregate all those
um all those data frames into one using
Union and reduce
and then we use the windows functions
in order to calculate what's happening
in in the three days before and the four
in the four day before and so on
window functions and you might know them
from SQL
or pandas
um what we want to do is take all our
data points and our relevance day and
actually create some kind of an
aggregation
to see how many categories days above a
bob had five days before ending on the
run date how many searches how many
detail pages
how many searches two days before
and the same for Alice
so
in SQL it's also called the Windows
window functions and in a file does it's
expanding and rolling a functions
when we are
um talking about expanding Windows uh we
actually talk about inclusive which
means the first and second day and the
first and the second to the third day
and a rolling window we're talking about
data points that are exclusive
when we're using pi spark when when we
want to use by spark when we are dealing
with a large a very large data sets
and we also use Windows window functions
so when we're creating a window and we
aggregate them by the ID of the users
and the Run dates and we ordered them by
date
and arrange a starting a start point and
an end point
and those starting and endpoints are
actually what we're
um we're playing with if we want to do
it inclusive or exclusive
so
under that time window
we can create all kind of different
functions it can be some average or
standard deviation
and then we can use that to create more
features to our data frame
again it can be exclusive or exclusive
it it depends on the the range and the
starting and the beginning and the
starting and the ending of the range
so this is an example for how it will be
how it will look if we're taking just
the day before
and over the time window and we want to
aggregate the sum of the events
the final aggregation on the Merit
features is we look something like that
and we will aggregate those columns in
order to achieve
um the aggregation of all the dates for
a specific a
specific type of events
um for a categorical feature it will
look a little bit something like that
and you're just using Group by instead
of pivoting
and what's next what after we're done
with all the category features we just
content them and just see how what what
is the counts and the average and all
kind of
um of aggregation of those feature
and the next thing we can use is NLP to
sequence a behavior of of customers
the customer funnel
um is all kind of events
um that are different from the
uniqueness of of the their uh of the
events so when
when we're just seeing little pages and
searching like for uh for hotels or
something like that there are a lot of
events that are similar to that but then
again we're checking for specific uh
um product it's it's less it's more and
more unique
um
in in order to wait to those events we
can use a TF IDF methods
and we can use those methods methods in
order to wait different kind of of
events in our customer funnel um
um
and but when we're just waiting those
events we don't give any attention for
the order of the events
so when we're taking a concept it's
called anagram from NLP we can actually
model our the sequence the the sequence
themselves
of of the the
um
of the events in the customer funnel
but this is all of those topics and how
to model a user Behavior using NLP it's
for longer
um Talk
and during this talk more than one and a
half billion sales that died in your
body
during during this this lecture
and this is it for this lecture thank
you